Hi, my, my, Pooh!
Hello,
everybody.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Howdy.
Hi, hello.
She's here.
I am here.
Here, here, here.
Hello,
hello, hello.
Oh, con minto.
Freaking minto's in town.
The freaking minto's in town and the clowns are out to play,
baby.
Wait, did I?
I don't even think I tweeted today.
I'm so out of it.
Did I?
No, I didn't.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so out of it today.
To be fair, I haven't really been on my computer so much.
I've been haunting elsewhere.
There we go.
Yes.
Who are you calling us?
I'm not calling you clowns.
Maybe we can all be clowns together.
Conminto sounds like, it sounds in Spanish like conminto
equals with me.
Minto.
Well, you are, I guess.
Con Minto.
Um.
Clown together strong.
Con Minto.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
My, I've mentioned I haven't really been on my computer
today because I was slaving away stuff trying to get it
ready for the debut today that has been rescheduled.
My outfit debut has been rescheduled to Monday.
Monday, Monday, Monday.
But you know about
maybe like 45 minutes of my day was in battle I was locked
into battle with a wasp that entered my cafe and I said no
no no on the toilet no not in battle on the toilet I don't
think I I'm worried for you guys don't get the explosive
diarrhea if you live in the u.s don't get that quit eating
your greens
i hope i didn't make you sad with my tree ornament super
tight yesterday i hope you're having a good day oh no you
didn't at all maddie you know honestly it's just funny that
you made me uh you reminded me that i forgot mine but it's
no worries
I just want to be skinny for off Kai.
Bossy, okay, have a snack and some water.
Have a great day.
Thank you, new servers.
Thank you very much for the server time.
Thank you, thank you.
I was in battle with the wasp.
And I was washing dishes.
And I turned.
And I see it on the window crawling up.
And I was like.
hell hell and so I took my my vacuum and I was like oh
you're gonna get sucked baby you do not get to go to pass go
you do not get to collect $200 you are you do not you are
not welcome here guys Stop blushing!
This is a matter of death or death!
Stop!
So, yeah.
So, I was like, okay, you're getting the tube, the vacuum.
And luckily my vacuum has like a really long tube on it and
you can take off the top of, like the bottom of it and it
just becomes like a long, long tube.
like i'm gonna get you i'm gonna get you i'm gonna get you
and i it like it like i had to i had to like look at it from
other angles it like disappeared for a little while and i
was like well maybe there's a hole in my i mean it's an
abandoned mage cafe so maybe there's a hole in my window
and he made his way out and i was i was literally like
locked onto the window for maybe like 10 minutes or
something waiting for it to crawl around and then I see it
slowly descending down and it's sandwiched in between my so
like my window was slightly open right to let in a breeze
and it was in that like overlapping part of the windows Good
job sucking that wasp, boss.
Also, it's my birthday today.
My buddy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Why ghost made hate?
Spinator.
Because he's not supposed to be in my house.
But, um...
Glad you didn't accidentally get sucked in the vacuum with
it.
Don't worry.
My vacuum is not.
for ghosts it is for wasps so I nobody likes waspinator
weakest decepticon agreed agreed agreed no I like how he
goes waspinator I wish I had a fig I would fig that guy the
wasp but New roommate?
I don't have enough room for a roommate.
Another roommate.
And, um, I was holding my vacuum prepped for battle.
Like, locked in.
I go in for the kill.
I shove my tube into the wasp.
click the button to start the vacuum, I miss.
Luckily, I think he was shocked.
I think he was shocked and fell.
And so then I was like, turn.
My turn.
My chance to win it all.
And I shoved it and sucked him up.
And he was spinning in there.
I was watching him spin and spin and spin around.
and I was like, yeah, yeah, get tubed, get tubed, and I,
actually, what time is it, let's see, this happened around,
I remember when it happened, because I messaged the group
chat, I was like, there's a wasp in my cafe, uh, this
happened about, three hours ago,
Yeah, three hours ago.
And I vacuumed my entire cafe with him spinning, spinning,
spinning, spinning around.
Spinning, spinning, spinning around.
And I vacuumed my whole cafe and I put it even on, I put it
on max, max sucking mode.
And so it was like, and he was going, he's still alive.
I checked right before stream.
He's still alive!
The most resilient, the toughest of bugs!
Giving Matara Khan a run for her money.
This is what Kojima wanted for the end fight.
And here I thought you didn't like turn-based combat.
etching you into its memories honestly it does kind of feel
like that because it will stare at me with its big beady
eyes like it'll be crawling around in there amongst the dust
and hair and then and then it will like stop and stare at me
and be like you you and every time i think it's gone to hell
every time i think it's dead and gone to hell it'll start
moving and crawling around again and I'm like maybe it did
die and go to hell and the devil was just like you're too
evil you need to get out it's gonna build a hive in the
vacuum no it whoa it's it's like dying next time pull out
the revolver tricks I'm not I'm not as good as that guy I'm
gonna have holes in my window
I mean so hello when I was a kid oh I cannot say the bugs
name today sorry I swatted multiple times ended up biting me
they're very resilient well YouTube get mad if you share the
art from your new reference sheet on stream I heard it's
pretty scary mama cooked I don't think so I don't think
YouTube will get mad I think it's fine, probably.
I had a weird dream that my kitchen faucet was leaking and
you were my plumber.
Plumber dream, Minto, was bullying me about the house.
My house is poor plumbing hygiene.
I woke up thoroughly flabbergasted.
I don't even know how to...
I don't...
I don't know...
I've never cleaned the pipes before ever.
When can we get the Netflix anime adaptation of this
episode?
epic battle.
I'm pitching it right now.
You might want to just put the dustbin outside for a bit
before he figures out how to climb out on his own.
I've checked, that's why I've been checking him.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for the super chats too.
I've been checking on him because I'm like, what if he does
crawl out?
So scary.
Thank you.
Jimmy, welcome back.
Check out Assault Gun.
Shoot flies but then you have to clean up the salt can we
have a virtual hug today?
Needed a little hug today.
I'll send you a hug over as well.
No!
Use it to you now!
Virtual hug.
A wasp in your vacuum.
Free me from this blasted prison at once you went to...
Wow, okay.
Today I learned that stream labs allows the word wench to be
sent through.
Today I learned.
How offensive.
Offensive.
Whoa!
Vanilla!
Thank you so much for the Aqua sofa.
Tomorrow is my birthday.
Thank you for another year of being the best comment.
I was saying, Ibu, could ask for you an awesome community
you've cultivated.
Make me so proud of you.
And here's to 10,000 more years of cheering you on as you
chase your dreams!
Vanilla!
Happy!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Tomorrow is a collab, so it might be a little difficult to
wish it to you.
So I'm glad.
Just play this tomorrow.
Just play it.
Happy birthday to you!
today I had a really important interview I had to fly out
for it and returning back later tonight have a good stream
have a safe flight Cody wait that's crazy good luck good
luck good luck today's stream might be a little bit shorter
because I'm
feeling I'm feeling I'm feeling pretty
Since my Alpha debut was supposed to be today, I do have a
little more extra time to prepare some things that I didn't
completely finish ironing out.
Lovecraft, welcome to Membership Diakyo!
I don't know.
It's been a...
Not so awesome couple of last days, so I'm just feeling
like...
It's all hitting me.
me today um yeah so ironing the outfit yeah i have too many
wrinkles too many wrinkles right um but i didn't want to not
stream and i don't want to just be a downer uh so uh yeah
let's just play a little bit of dave the diver and then i'll
head off little bro gonna be planning his vengeance be
careful me though maybe as a ghost but what is he gonna do
ghosting me hey i'm beat though i'm glad you decided to
stream today i hope we can be a fun distraction for you also
curious did you get the art made of you with a drop bear you
wait did you get art made of you with a drop bear you
mentioned on the podcast yes i did i did draw that i did
draw that wait i think i Hold on, I can show you guys.
We were in, we were at SmashCon Australia.
And we had, um, we had little postcards given out to people
that came to the meet and greet.
And, uh, I said in the Den Setu podcast on our Patreon, I
said, I kind of want to draw me getting mauled by a drop
bear.
Do you think that's too...
No, I wasn't silent.
No.
I was like, do you think that's too...
You know.
Something.
I don't know.
Too violent.
And...
Phoebe and Vicky were like, No.
It sounds great.
You should do it.
And so all of our little sketches turned out so fun this was
mine me getting mauled by the drop bear while you watch in
horror there's blood splattering everywhere wait maybe I can
hold on let me open it in like paint they have a better
there we go One second.
There it is.
Yeah, it's red ectoplasm.
At the end of Smash, I thank Steiner for his effort and he
gave me my friend a card despite not winning the meet and
greet.
The sketches were amazing.
Ah, that's awesome!
Yeah, I want more people, you know.
Our drawings are so cute.
I think.
Yeah, you look great for being mauled by a drop bear.
Thank you.
It's actually cranberry juice.
Not blood.
Full of all that cranberry juice.
I tried today.
I love cranberry juice.
And usually when you get cranberry juice, it's very...
It's not actual cranberry juice.
You know what I mean?
But I love it.
I was told about a a 100% real cranberry juice cranberry
juice like the ingredient says cranberry juice yeah it's
usually they mix it yes yeah yeah yeah or it's like apple
juice or something yeah yeah yeah and so I I was very
excited for the 100% cranberry juice cranberry juice and
it was I it was 100% I can still feel the tartness in my
mouth it was so strong but I mixed it with orange juice and
it was great It was not a scam.
Not at all.
Holy heck though.
It was so...
I could feel my mouth puckering just hearing this.
That it was truly.
Just cranberry is something else.
It was... It's good.
They have cranberry juice in Australia.
Probably, right?
They have cranberry juice everywhere.
Drop bears are definitely real though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cute and horrifying, well done.
I hope we ganked up on that drop berry and chased it off of
you.
Now...
Sorry, I heard something.
I thought...
I thought my Metal Gear cabinet was collapsing.
100% cranberry makes you realize why they mix it.
It's crazy!
It's crazy how tart it is.
The wasp?
No!
No, no, no.
More to-do-do-do.
Thank you so much for 37 months.
Thank you.
But, uh.
Pure pomegranate juices like that too.
So good, but so tired.
Oh, really?
I've never tried, I think, a pure pomegranate.
Hmm.
Just saw the announcement of Denizutsu.exe making appearance
at Anime Thon.
Would have preferred Otaku Thon instead since y'all came to
Oshi Uplink.
I thought, okay, fine, let Western Canada have their moment
for what?
Yeah, we have to hit up lots of different places.
Sorry.
Hmm.
I would also like to apologize for not being born a peanut.
Wait, what?
I'm sorry I should have been born a peanut.
Oh, yeah.
That's also from the podcast, doesn't it?
Fun fact, craisins are supposed to be dried cranberries.
As sweet as raisins are.
mostly added by sugar wait wait craisins which are supposed
to be dried cranberries as sweet as raisins are mostly added
sugar by weight no i love craisins though i put them in my
oatmeal every day no don't tell me that no good day mint
it's my first time here i saw your panel on performance at
smash con i hope you enjoyed it it was such a fun time well
thanks for joining thank you Happy to have you here.
I'm glad you had fun.
They're good, but mostly sugar.
No.
Don't tell me that.
Wait.
I saw you once when you were haunting Anime Ottawa, but I
was too shy to come say hi.
So I'm saying hi now.
Hi, Minto.
Hello, Green Shadow.
I hope I see you at another con.
Maybe Canada.
I bought my animaithon ticket an hour ago can't wait thank
you see you there yeah we were we're very excited about our
appearance at animaithon because we'll be in this festival
this music festival that they host and basically performing
on the same stage is like I don't I mass shiny colors and
I'm like That's crazy!
Tim Tim, thank you so much for the five gifted.
40 grams of dried craisins have 26 grams of added sugar!
I'm gonna cry!
Here I thought I was having the most healthy breakfast ever!
No!
Wait, I gotta check my thing now.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh, that is so much sugar.
No.
Yuck.
Breakfast is ruined.
My breakfast is oatmeal plus cranberries, I guess craisins,
plus craisins plus peanuts and other nuts.
And a little thing of peanut butter for extra peanut taste.
And then I mix, mix, mix, mix, mix, mix, mix.
And sometimes if I'm feeling frisky, I add honey.
But it's not frisky.
If I felt like buying honey.
Yeah.
Spicy honey?
No.
I'm not a fan of the spicy honey craze.
In fact, I'm a spicy honey auntie.
I think...
I think I should be able to have my savory sweets without...
Without it having to be spicy!
Like, I love going to Japan and getting honey on pizza.
It's so delicious.
yummy yummy but then in the states they're like we're also
putting honey on pizza but it's spicy honey i'm like why you
already have the sweet and the savory with the pizza why
does it have to be spicy
sugar without spice is perfectly nice yeah
what's even the point i don't know Hot honey is good.
Spicy honey is awesome.
Deny!
No!
What about for all these ghosts that can't have spicy?
Now I'm denied my honey with pizza.
Then have an option with regular honey too.
If you're gonna have...
If you're gonna have a hot honey, then you need to have...
You need to have a regular honey version too.
Spicy honey had a coupon.
me I can't have spicy I can't have spicy denied I'm denying
you I'm a big fan of honey in all forms no way where where
what how could I have guessed that simp honey you need to
put a four in between your name wait simp honey for two wait
Is it that you are a simp for honey for two?
So how much of a...
What would be a serving size of honey for two people?
Honey for two, please.
But my spice mint.
You can have spicy.
I just don't want it.
The whole jar.
Okay.
Good.
Two bees.
nest worth.
That's a lot of honey.
Waiter brings out a bowl of honey with two straws.
Ew.
Bee movie, watch a long win.
Only if we can all recite the movie together.
And we'll just act it out together.
You could put your own honey on the pizza.
Oh, I have.
I have.
I have done that.
I'm going to play Dave the Diver now.
We're playing the...
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
Wait.
I forgot.
I got to get rid of me getting mauled.
There we go.
We're going to end it at drinking hot.
honey out of straws but oh that kind of makes me want bubble
tea I said no I well I was like I want to get ice cream
because it's so hot I was like I want to get ice cream after
my debut for like a successful job well done but now my
debut is not today so I have to wait
Mr. Crabbs, play the world's tiniest violin.
You can still get ice cream?
No, I shouldn't.
Because then I'm rewarding myself for nothing.
I didn't do anything.
I should reward myself for a job well done.
If it is a job well done.
I caught my roommate chugging honey out of a bottle.
The thing that surprised me...
Wait, what?
Is that like a reference to something?
Treat yourself to something else for always doing a job well
done.
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna!
You won against a...
Wasp today.
My stutter is so bad today, sorry.
Mwah!
oh my gosh thank you so much for the third ever super
victory toast I'll think about it I'll think about it I you
guys go to a my gosh I
go to a local ice cream place that has a really good fudge.
We get ice cream if I did a good job today.
Did you, man?
Did you do a good job today?
I'm sure you did.
Surely a victor of honorable combat deserves a little candy
of your choice.
I'll think about it.
I'll see how I'm feeling afterwards.
I miss actual ice cream shop ice cream.
My favorite place actually is Coldstone.
My favorite place to go for ice cream is Coldstone.
They make it so creamy.
It's so delicious.
I love a Coldstone creamery.
Coldstone hits when you get a good one.
Yeah, it's so yummy.
Orga!
Welcome back.
I read in a story once that singing words that you're
stuttering can help.
It uses different parts of the brain language.
It was fiction, but maybe worth trying to test by...
Maybe.
What would I sing?
For good, you can see that.
I tried Haagen-Dazs once.
No ice cream can compare?
No, I swear.
Cold stone.
The way they, like, take the ice cream and, like, mash it
and smash it on the ice bar.
And then...
And then they put your things in there.
Your toppings.
And then they mash it and smash it all together.
And it's all nice and...
All nice and...
It...
Creamy.
so good it's so good cold stone is so good yeah i've had
cold stone it's pretty amazing yeah you gotta mash it and
smash it do they still sing if you tip them they don't but
honestly i don't mind i don't i don't i don't need the
performance Cold Stone Austin Steve My favorite wrestler
Cold Stone Steve Austin Who is this?
Wait, I gotta look this up Oh,
I wrote Stephen Stone Cold Steve Austin No No, it's cold
stone.
Wait, is it cold stone?
Wait.
Stone cold.
No.
Wait.
I know someone who does sing when you tip them.
Oh!
This is my tipping song.
Thank you for the tip.
It really helps me out.
This is my tipping song.
Thank you so much for the tip.
I'm gonna go get ice cream.
Coldstone's got great ice cream, but DQ's got the best ice
cream cakes.
Oh, I don't know.
I've never tried some other ice cream cakes.
The Dairy Queen.
Wait, so the...
Hold on.
The ice cream is called Coldstone.
And the wrestler is Stone Cold.
Stone Cold Steve Austin.
And he goes...
Why does he not had a collaboration with Stone Cold?
In Australia, our version of is Cold Rock Ice Creamery.
So it's similar.
Ducky!
Thanks so much for the tip.
This is my tipping song.
This is the tipping song.
Thank you so much for the tip.
The Cold Stone Steve.
Steve is cold.
If he's cold, wait.
If you're cold, he is cold.
Let him in.
He's cold and he's stone and he's let him in.
He's cold and he's stone and he's Steve Austin.
He's cold and he's cold and he's stone and he's Steve
Austin.
He's already retired.
We are at the Jungle Life, baby.
I guess we just did, uh, what do you call it?
The restaurant.
Back in the 90s, WWE had Mike Tyson as a guest and he
mistakenly called Stone Cold Austin Cold Stone Steve Austin.
Someone was thinking of someone had ice cream on the brain.
Oh, that's right.
There's crocodiles and stuff.
There's this thing we can do where we can upgrade our house.
House repairs.
You got wooden vines?
Yeah.
Nice work.
Let's fix this place up.
That must have taken some effort.
So just sit back and watch.
Stop talking about stones.
I mean, old, cold stones.
Cold stone.
I'm getting hungry.
Very neat.
It looks much better now.
Thanks.
Well, there's not much I can sell around here.
At least I can do it, right?
The place still feels a bit empty, though.
The village chief said we can use it however we like.
So let's decorate it with some furniture.
Hot stones.
But also, when your ice cream melts a little bit and you can
slurp it up.
Delicious.
Come to think about Bancho's place, you can probably use a
few things, too.
Why don't you go ask Bancho?
prepared too so we'll probably need a few things got it
talk to banjo wait what's in my phone oh maybe it's a to-do
yeah mysterious oh yeah the utara crystals give we gotta
give these away give these two there he is about the matara
crystal looks like i missed out on my cold stone era The
only one left in Hawaii is on Maui.
No!
Is that far from you?
If you ever make it to mainland, I guess, maybe.
I was also...
Like, uh...
Basque and Robbins took over Japan.
So when I was first initially, like, thinking that I would
be moving to Japan instead, um...
I looked to see if they had any cold stone.
I was like, I wonder, please, please, do you have a cold
stone?
Yeah, Sati 1 is what they call it.
They can't say Baskin Robbins, so they call it 31.
But, what was it?
They had one in, like, Hokkaido, and it was closed.
And I was so sad.
Oh, so they have none.
Only Baskin Robbins everywhere.
Yeah, Sati 1.
Here they are.
Should be more than enough.
First, I've made some simple tools using the crystals I've
gathered.
If you bring me more Matara crystals, I can continue my
research.
Got it.
I'll pick them up whenever I spot any.
Nice.
Coldstone and Tim Hortons to experience for my first time in
my future.
I heard Timmy is not so great anymore, though.
Tim Hortons.
But I think I've only had it once, so...
It would also suck if you lived in Tokyo and had to go to
Hokkaido to get Cold Stone.
Why would they have it all the way there?
It fell off, sadly.
It's gone downhill in the States!
It fell off when Burger King bought it.
That was like a couple years ago, right?
Like 10 years ago or something I heard.
I've just been wanting to try both.
Yeah, I know it's originally Canadian.
It only came to the States recently.
It's trash SWE's birthday!
Oh, sorry, I missed it!
Happy birthday!
I'm so sorry, I missed it, I missed it.
Happy, happy birthday!
As a Canadian, it's never been amazing, but it's still
extraordinarily cheap relative to other places.
You know, I hear that about, like, In and Out, where so many
people rave about In and Out that, like, it gets this crazy
reputation for being, like, the ultimate delicious
hamburger, like, burger joint, and then when you go, it's
just kind of like, oh, that was yummy, and they use fresher
ingredients, and, yeah, that was pretty good, but nothing
like what people hype it up to be.
But, at the same time, at the same time, You have to kind of
put it into perspective where it's like, you're getting a
nice fresh burger for a good price.
And maybe it's not like the most fantastic, stupendous
burger you've ever had ever in your afterlife, but...
But for a good price, it cannot be beat, I'd say.
Hmm.
Hmm, I think so.
It's dependable.
That's a good way to put it.
I also really like In and Out, though.
I used to be, like, like, a, man, In and Out is so
overrated.
Man, the fries there taste like styrofoam.
And then I, one day, it started craving, like, I was, like,
missing the styrofoam fries.
I was like, what?
Why do I miss these styrofoam fries?
and I've been Stockholm syndromed into loving their
styrofoam fries.
Mito, the C's have been on job interview calls all day and
will be tomorrow as well.
Please give me a strike.
Brian, you got this.
All you have to do is do the calls and then once you got the
job, you're done.
And you're going to get a great, amazing job because you're
great and amazing.
You got this.
Yeah, in and out.
I love eating now!
Yeah!
Me too.
I don't know.
I think I really came to like In and Out.
But I have a local burger place that I discovered that I'm
like...
This might be my place.
Styrofoam fries.
Hashtag not spines.
Let's have a data in and out.
We'll go to In and Out.
and we'll we'll date and you can feed me styrofoam fries and
i'll happily accept them she's a styrofoam girl
i'm very usually particular about my fries
do they squeak like styrofoam when you chew them no they
just have like a strange consistency can anybody agree can
anybody everybody agree with me even if you've never had
them before can you disagree with me I didn't like in and
out until I asked them animal style while adding chopped
chilies wait chopped which you can skip and extra grilled
onions oh whoever
said no dishonor dishonor on you and your family They're not
even in my country.
Just agree, disagree.
I kind of want in and out now.
I kind of miss it.
Designer on your cow.
Yeah, we completed the mission.
Bacon's lab.
Oh, we can now buy items.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
I'd like to buy in your lab.
Ammo box immediately refills the ammo of the gun currently
in use.
Wait, this is nice, no?
Is this one-time use?
I think it's getting kind of late for in-game.
I think we might be able to still talk to Bancho, though.
have time before it tells us to go to sleep.
What is it?
How's the cooking going?
Looks like the villagers will be coming too.
Yes, but it's a refill you can carry with you.
Okay, okay.
Funds for Styrofoam fries.
Thank you, Sifu!
Thank you!
What is...
Various VTuber Fast Food Meal Challenges are going around on
Twitter.
What is it?
What is the Mint Phantom Meal Challenge?
Wait, what's the Meal Challenge?
challenge.
Wait, I don't know it.
Wait, what?
What's the meal challenge?
It's an abomination.
That doesn't tell me.
What is your go-to fast food order?
Well, it was Taco Bell, but I don't know anymore.
I'm gonna get explosive diarrhea if I go there.
Remember I actually thought, okay, there was an episode of
South Park where they said that anybody that eats Chipotle
pooped blood and I believe that for a really long time.
So I never had Chipotle until like a year ago or something.
But I feel like they were prophesizing something a little
bit.
Because now
it's real!
Oh my gosh!
For anybody who doesn't know, there's like a horrible virus
going around the United States that they're not quite
entirely sure where it's from.
But they believe it's produce that hasn't been...
Or rather, produce that has had like some sort of parasite
that dug itself and laid its eggs in the...
in the produce.
Yeah, it's the parasite, the parasite.
Domino's Pizza won't stop emailing me.
Pizza places are going up, up, up.
They don't have any lettuce on their stuff.
And they're connecting it to Taco Bell because Taco Bell was
like one of the first places to remove certain items off of
their menu, which is quite suspect maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
To be fair, Chipotle had a lot of E.
coli problems years ago.
Oh, did they?
I had no idea.
Vocal cord parasite?
No, lettuce parasite.
It's in Europe, too.
Oh, yeah, it's not like a new thing.
It's just like having a bit of an outbreak here.
people are getting explosive diarrhea because of it.
So um so don't eat your greens at this very moment.
Maybe.
It sucks because I just started a diet.
No!
Maybe this is the universe going against you.
Maybe it's Your fault!
But it also has like an incubation period of two weeks or
something.
So...
Be careful.
I caught Taco Bell like...
Just a couple days ago.
I've cooked, you guys.
At Ofkai, if you smell something, no you didn't.
It could be any way.
and to be honest.
Merrick would be like, oh, there I go, Shiden again.
Don't eat lettuce before off, Kai.
Worst mistake of my life.
Sorry for the disgusting conversation.
But...
This, this is...
Sometimes it's sad to talk about news.
Going around.
But this is a news that is not so bad.
or rather it's bad but it's not depressing maybe yeah it's a
PSA it's a P it's bad but also very funny yeah the fact that
everybody is describing it in the same way as like an ex
literally everyone being like this is an explosive diarrhea
it's just so bad
It's so bad.
Everyone's describing it in the same way.
And I don't want to know what they mean by that.
Really gotta emphasize how explosive it is.
Oh, yes, but yes, if you do have any symptoms, please go
seek medical attention.
It's very treatable.
But it might come back.
I think they said it could, like, happen, and then it could
go away for a little bit, like a month or something, and
then be like, psych.
Dying of dysentery.
Everybody ready?
Everybody hungry?
So we had the conversation of food, and then I made you lose
your appetite.
So you don't feel so hungry.
Yippee!
You're on the Oregon Trail.
I've been thinking recently about wanting to play original
Oregon Trail.
This is a public service announcement brought to you in part
by Mint Phantom.
Don't eat your greens.
Original Oregon...
Well, I guess maybe not the original one.
Because the original original is like...
What is like PC-98 or something, right?
Um...
The, I don't know.
It's like the one in between.
Who's a DOS?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, like a Windows 97 one.
I had Taco Bell today just like two days ago.
So today or two days ago?
Are you in Michigan?
If so?
Oh, seven's in the chat.
But yeah, the one, the not text-only Oregon Trail, but the
one that was like, had like, I don't know, pictures.
It was so unhinged.
Was it PC-98?
It's so unhinged.
The hunting minigame.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
PC-99, the Japanese computer that Falcom made most games on.
Dissentary.
True story, Rockstar remade Oregon Trail and then called it
Red Dead Redemption 2.
I want to play.
So bad.
It's like so long, though.
What's stopping you?
Mainly the length.
But I really, really want to play it.
OG Organ Trail video game was text-based only.
Came out in 71.
Ah, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you, Morris.
Thank you, thank you.
Try Organ Trail.
I've heard of it, but I've never played it.
the zombie Oregon Trail.
Just out of curiosity, who else here intentionally didn't
stock up on enough food so that they wouldn't have to go, so
that they would have to go hunting?
So fair.
And Red Dead Redemption too, I think I would want to take it
really slow.
I think I would like, there's so many little side things you
can do.
So many interesting, it's one of those games that they're
still discovering things about, even to this day.
Like, there's just, I just, I don't know.
And I've thought about it.
I was like, how could I play this game?
Because like, doing it weekly might be like, you know,
because it would be weekly for like a year, you know?
It would be like weekly for a year.
And that's like a lot of time taken up on my schedule.
MGSV will be long enough.
Yeah, but I intend to play V with mod, so it might speed it
up a tad.
A certain cowgirl VTuber did a reading of fellow VTubers
who'd survived the Oregon Trail.
Suffice to say, you and Mataro were at the top of the list.
On survival?
Yeah, yep!
I'd live, except I'm dead.
Okay, maybe later this year then.
I know I'm gonna cry during it.
That's the thing too.
But maybe after some of my bigger events are over, I can
start it.
Red Dead...
Like a Red Dead Sundays or something.
Okie dokie Sorry, I keep forgetting I'm playing a game Me
Picks a game to play today Also me The ingredients in this
region seem better suited for skewers A proper skewer grill
would be ideal A skewer grill, that's not something we can
just make ourselves Maybe the carpenter could help us out
Can we go talk to him Will it tell us to go to...
Who are you?
Hello, my name is Dave.
I'll be staying in this village for a while.
Hello.
Oh, I'm sorry.
She's crying.
Are you crying?
I'm sorry.
I spoke to you at a bad time.
No, it's all right.
I was looking at the lake and remembered when Jaka, my
husband, used to play there.
I'm Sinta, and I live in this village with my son.
We haven't had visitors in quite some time.
It's nice to see someone from outside again.
Though some people might not be too happy about it.
I'll do my best not to cause any trouble.
My Jaka dreams of going to the city someday and becoming a
musician.
He's a bit shy, so he may not approach you at first, but if
you have any advice, I'd really appreciate it.
Cintra.
Oh no, he's not here!
Please!
The door is closed.
Dang it.
Oh, okay.
Go to bed.
There we go.
Nice.
Are you sleeping?
I can't wait to go fishing.
Oh my gosh!
It's December!
Do you remember?
The first of December.
I dreamed about food.
Now I'm starving.
This place is looking nice and clean now.
Maybe I could add a few decorations.
Oh, we could decorate!
Well, everybody's running around.
What is happening?
What is it?
What are our quests to do's?
This!
We have to photograph the first stone tablet.
Boncho's cooking.
Talk to the carpenter.
And then whatever the animal block showdown thing is.
Alright.
We'll ignore the alien guys for now and we'll go to this
hello are you he sniffing me ew do i smell hydrogen sulfide
yes that's oh it's this guy the guy that came from the uf
hall you have a keen nose i know that smell well we
sometimes get it during experiments at the lab.
But why is it so strong near the lake?
Sniffer, sniffer.
I'm Muna, a researcher.
I couldn't help overhearing.
Let me explain.
Hydrogen sulfide forming layers from biological remains is a
natural phenomenon.
But as you may have seen from the carcass at Lake Beach,
ancient creatures started rising from the bottom of the lake
one day.
They were either poisoned by hydrogen sulfide on the way up
and died.
Do you guys believe in Nessie?
The building of corpses keeps fueling the cycle, increasing
the hydrogen sulfide concentration.
That's what this genius Muna has figured out.
Hmm.
Yeah, I want to in some capacity.
It wasn't proven fake.
Nessie is out there.
I see.
The situation isn't normal.
At this rate, the lake's ecosystem could be in danger.
Is there a place at the bottom of the lake where clean water
flows out?
If so, we might be able to use some parts from my
spacecraft.
I think I might have seen something like that.
I'll check.
It'll take a while for the rescue team to arrive anyway.
Time to show what I can do.
Ha ha!
Let me know if you find a spot with clean water.
And tell me what the terrain looks like, too.
What a teethy smile.
I believe in Nessie like I believe in ghosts so you do
entirely right right
Nessie is real trust clam
grooming oh wait This one's worse than what I had before.
Oh!
I'm sorry!
I didn't see you there!
His cousin Nahuelito lives down here, so it has to be real.
Exactly!
Matoru Crystal.
Ah!
I hate these guys.
Kill them with my fists.
Nice.
So if we're...
If we're looking for...
The other stone tablet.
Lamb and Grants.
Scary guy, scary guy.
Run away, run away.
Sunang inscribed stone tablet.
Oh, wait, how do I...
Oh, shoot!
Oh!
Ouch.
Oh wait, why is it not working?
Am I forgetting how to shoot?
Oh, there we go.
I'm dumb.
Wait,
is this the net one?
Oh, he broke through it!
Oh no.
I think we got him.
Yay!
That's a big guy right there.
What is this?
A lift bag!
Oh, here we go, here we go, I found it.
Before we take a photo, though, let's grab some other stuff.
Nice.
The little people.
Okay.
Not exactly sure what's going on, but it looks like they're
gathering, they're gathered doing something.
Alright, I've got all photos of the tablets.
I should head back to Moona.
Wait, my head is blocking him.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, we're in trouble.
We might be in trouble.
Just keep going.
He won't follow me up.
He won't follow me up!
Long boy.
Piranha was coming after me too.
I was gonna say I have to grab somebody.
We need some stuff for dinner.
You!
Come on, me, isn't it?
Wait, aren't these, uh...
These are popular, no?
Yeah, the tilapia, yeah.
I was like, it's not tuna.
We'll grab a bunch for dinner?
Oh, try the net on the smallfish.
You're so right.
one right?
Wait, come back?
Nice and fresh?
Oh yeah, five stars.
Oh no, I'm out!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yes.
Now I'm gonna get a group of them.
Oh, just kidding.
Wait, is tilapia really an invasive species no way is it
really maybe someone told me that last time but I don't
remember oh I got two of them I got two of them their other
friend is oblivious and stupid
hmm oh that's a scary looking guy you see him I get closer
to him so you guys can see but I don't really want to I'm
only doing it for you guys.
Alright, here we go.
Boost!
Oh shoot.
Yeah.
They taste too good to be invasive, right?
Nice.
Let's go talk to Mona.
Continue with the story.
Mona!
Wait, can I upgrade this now?
I think so.
I need one more.
There might be just a Matara stone lying around.
Wait, what does my girlfriend need?
Yes, my queen?
Mom.
Oh, Dave, have you happened to see any lizards around the
village?
I think so, but they're so quick I couldn't get a good look.
You might already know, but I raise lizards.
Lizards!
Some people are scared of big, aggressive lizards.
But the big-eyed lizards I raise are gentle and really
adorable but because they taste good they often end up as
prey for wild animals that's why I keep them at home to
protect and breed them oh those big guys are really are cute
if you're interested Dave why not try catching one are we
gonna cook the lizard I I hope not I don't even have a place
to keep it don't worry about raising it just bring it to me
they come in all kinds of colors and patterns but the most
common one is the big blue big
blue big eye we're not gonna eat them right sounds
interesting but they run off the moment I get close you
won't catch one just by walking up to it big eye lizards are
timid but they let their guard down completely when they're
eating they're cute but that's exactly why they get caught
by predators so easily i'll give you some lizard bite place
it a short distance away then step back wait for it to start
eating and you'll be able to catch it so i just set this
down near one and wait yes if you need more lizard bait i
can sell you some got it i'll give it a try
yes yes give me a lizard
lizard there there there wait how do I put the bait down how
do I put the bait down
go to items snail bait bait bait maybe
too far
oh my god oh my god he's a Big-eyed lizard!
Did she catch a...
I can't say it.
Lizard?
Yes.
Oh my, you really brought one.
Isn't it just adorable?
The lake blue color is so lovely.
Big-eyed lizards come in many colors besides blue.
If you bring me rare ones, I'll reward you.
Sounds good.
I'll keep an eye out while I'm around.
Oh!
We're so in you.
We're so...
We're so in.
Let the flower garden right by next to my house, I can enjoy
the scent of flowers anytime.
When you fall asleep around by a lovely fragrance, you won't
have any bad dreams, you know.
We're so in.
And we're so in...
This thing is still decaying over here.
It's terrible.
It looks so bad.
It looks so bad now.
Wait.
No way.
Is that a toy doll right there?
You guys see him?
What is this thing?
It's a diving beetle.
Ew, I thought it was a little baby.
Turtle.
It's quite rotten.
Imagine the smell.
I don't want to.
Ah, I want some star fruit.
Wait!
That's our final Matara!
That's the one that we were looking for.
Matara crystal.
Right here.
It's even her colors.
It's kind of crazy.
Me, Tara, Matara, U, Tara.
This would be like Animal Crossing if not for the giant
corpse, you're right.
You're so right.
We Tara.
You Tara.
Wait, can I buy the research?
Lift bag sticky net.
Tara oxygen generator.
Power booster enables fast travel.
Cool, neat.
Oh, whoops.
Sorry, I didn't mean to press this.
There we go.
Let's talk to her.
A photo of the stone tablet.
Hmm.
Comparing this photo of the stone tablet with the previous
artifacts, this seems the ancient Sunang people used
something like a breathing apparatus.
That would make sense.
They couldn't have gone down there with nothing, just
holding their breath.
Matara on the brain, Matara in the city.
I've had to bug Matara recently about a lot of stuff, so she
is on my brain.
That looks as you're about to ask for something.
That breathing apparatus part, could it be at the bottom of
the lake?
That's definitely there, right?
All right, I'll try to find it.
But with the current purification filter, getting to the
bottom seems impossible.
Yeah, I've had to bug her.
I've had to bug her.
Oh, I take it an ounce!
I'm never told when things are going up.
They'll always like...
They'll always like go up.
And then I don't see because I don't check Twitter until
like tomorrow.
Yes, Matara will be a guest at um...
Out of Skyline Serenade!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
And what's fun is she and I will actually be singing in a
new original song together!
Yeah!
It's really fun.
It's fun, it's fun.
Yeah!
It's like a cool Eurobeat style.
and it has fun call where you go
new ori song yeah yeah yeah you heard it here first on Dave
the Diver stream wait is this what the pings were about
oh no they weren't did you guys get your hags hats have a
great summer I think I got it.
Well, it was first on the Matara podcast.
I guess that's true.
We did talk about it there.
We did.
I'll need larger bones and the fragments you brought earlier
to modify it.
I mean, things like skulls or vertebrae, you know.
Got it.
I'll grab them if I see any down there.
Thanks so much.
Hag's hats!
We have a Hag's hats too.
Wait, so...
Jungle gun.
Oh, I have enough money!
I think this is a new cutscene.
Oh, not the golden eye.
007 whoa she's bonding out you guys wait that was sick tin
ingot equipment enhance advanced oh I can make this I can
make this yeah make sure you read the fine print you get the
hat only hags are not included what are you talking about
having a summer is always included she's got aura she
reminds me of oticon maybe like a really strange oticon like
you know so now we got to go find the breathing apparatus
that's our that's our next goal there's so much what the
heck That's so cute.
There's always so much happening in this.
I'd say Otakon is pretty normal.
Otakon is strange?
You think so?
Definitely not as strange as Muna though.
Finally, a village with people.
Sato?
Dave, is that you?
What are the odds?
Water, please, just water first.
Yeah, here!
That hit the spot.
What are you doing out here?
I'm staying in the village with Dr. Bacon while we do some
research in the jungle.
Oh, got it.
Well, since we ran into each other, why did I stay here for
a while, too?
Of course not.
Not my village, but sure.
You can stay near the tents away from the villagers.
How did you end up all the way out here?
I was using this new app called...
Marinka Bloom.
Next thing I knew I was here.
Is that different from Marinka?
What is Marinka?
Exactly.
There were some complaints about the original app.
People would swim forever, walk for ages to collect Marinka,
but none of it was being tracked.
So they made a spin-off app.
Marinka Bloom.
Marinka Bloom tracks your steps and even your swimming
distance.
And all that gets turned into points to grow a giant flower
in the app.
Oh yeah, the Pokemon Go joke.
when the giant flower blooms you're supposed to get some
kind of reward though i haven't confirmed that yet still
working on my collection is this
is this a reference to something oh by the way did you bring
your phone yeah but most apps don't work here it's too
remote that's the best part marinka bloom uses the space
network no connection issues even out here Pikmin Bloom!
Actually, it's still in beta, so you need a friend code.
And you're in luck, I've got one left.
Wanna take your first step as...
Marinka Bloom Collector?
Sure?
How do I get started?
Take out your phone, I'll send you the code.
I got some kind of link.
It's for downloading ransomware.
Install it, basically.
It's like Marinka, catch fish, unlock cards, completion goes
up automatically.
But just collecting cards isn't enough to grow the seed.
You'll need to keep its health up.
This is too much.
This is a...
Sato!
I need nutrients and water.
This is so much work.
How do I get those?
That's where Marinka Bloom works his magic.
Your steps and swimming distance get converted into points.
Better try it yourself than listen to me, Rambo.
I'll be around the village, so just ask if you need
anything.
Choo!
I mean...
Mon mon!
Choo!
It's supposed to be recognizing your swimming distance and
you are not swimming, mister.
This DLC has so much stuff.
Oh yeah, we're gonna earn nutrients.
Flowers with low health can't grow to the next stage.
Anyway, I'll probably forget about that in two minutes.
This is the electric eel!
That's the guy that's been at me!
He's been after me!
Alright, we are looking for the thing.
The breathing apparatus.
I'm gonna get some leaks along the way.
And we can go even further deeper beyond because we got the
special...
We got even better stuff for our...
Oxygen, whatever it's called.
Our own breathing apparatus, I guess.
Yes!
They brought friends.
They have even more now.
Don't attack me.
No!
Don't corner me either.
Oh, he's dead, he's dead.
Yes, it only took three shots!
Three shots.
Fished house.
Yes!
Is this guy evil?
He's quite big.
No, he's not evil.
We're good.
We're good, we're good.
Alright.
But there's the eel right here.
Yes, this guy's evil.
I don't know if we'll be able to get this.
this guy maybe whoa oh shoot oh shoot
i'm out of bullets
we're so dead we're so dead holy cow wait i think there were
bullets wait where did i see some bullets i saw some use the
harpoon i guess we can just do that instead yeah Where do
you go?
We'll kill him, we'll kill him.
Oh!
That's not my heart, but...
He's so fast.
Oh!
Ouch!
Oh no!
Oh my god.
He's so strong.
What the?
Give up.
He's a dummy dumb.
Oh my gosh, ouch, ouch.
Oh no, no, no, no!
The strat is he can't turn very fast!
Oh shoot!
Oh shoot.
Guys, I'm scared!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I'm too slow!
I'm gonna die!
We did it!
Oh, we did it!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, yeah, we did it!
What's this?
Power booster.
I'm scared to go down.
I should get more of...
What's it called first?
Hold on.
Let's get some more O2.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, you have no idea.
No, please.
Leave me alone.
There's got to be something around here, right?
Please.
I think there's a gator in here.
Please, please, no!
Ouch!
He's still coming after me.
So persistent.
Alright, let's go down.
Everything's so evil.
Alright?
Oh, wait, some more, some more.
This is good, this is good.
Oh, hi.
Wait, is the gator here?
There was a gator around here, no?
I remember this egg.
Alright.
You can just catch it, too.
Catch what?
These hands?
They will.
Holy!
Oh!
Wait, no, my boomerang!
Is that?
Warren said to let him know if I found where clean water is
coming out.
I should head back up and tell him.
Oh, that's right!
Clean water!
Oh.
It's pretty murky down here.
It's pretty gross.
Is that the thing?
Looks like the breathing apparatus from the tablet earlier.
This must be what Munda was talking about.
I should take a closer look.
Oh my gosh.
No.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Get snipeed, snake-headed.
Yes.
Nice.
I still make out the shape.
I can still make out the shape, but it's too damaged.
I'm sure Dr. Breakin and Moona can figure something out.
Thank
you.
Oh, is that something just shook the lake from below?
Something's glinting in that pile of fallen branches.
I've never seen a mineral like this before.
I should take it with me.
I like how there's like fish.
Uh, hold on.
Wait, my big head.
Wait.
I'll go smaller and like not so in the corner.
But there's like little tiny fish underneath that guy.
It's so cute.
He looks like a grouper.
Is that a giant sturgeon?
Sweeping the bottom for food, huh?
It looks incredibly tough.
I'd better be careful.
But what's this?
Frog earthenware.
Sturgeon.
Looks even brighter up close.
I should find out what this is.
That aside, the hydrogen sulfide levels are really high
here.
I shouldn't go any deeper.
Okay.
I'll take some food for...
Oh.
Dang it.
For the restaurant.
That's your favorite fish.
These look like salmon.
Nope.
Are you guys salmon?
You guys are not afraid of me at all.
Grass carp.
I guess they're not pink enough, huh?
Now they are kind of tanky.
Carp, carp, carp, carp.
Yeah, seven has more pink to them, don't they?
Okay.
Got a good amount of stuff going on in here.
Oh, fragment.
Yes.
I'm gonna take this whole family.
Oh.
So I'm like, no, please, just let two of us live so that we
can...
Oh.
Repopulate.
Okay, okay.
I'll let two of you live.
Not because I wanted to, though.
Wait, what's the issue?
Wait.
Why?
Here, we'll use this.
Did it skip pod?
Oh, my filter!
That's right, I forgot I had a filter!
Yippee!
Wow, that was really productive, huh?
Nice.
Is he smelling me?
Hey, you!
The lake still stinks like hydrogen sulfide.
Yeah, you!
Did you happen to find... Yeah, you!
Did you happen to find where that clean water I mentioned
earlier comes from?
Yes, I found a spot where clean water is flowing out.
I was just about to tell you.
The current was really strong, so I couldn't get inside.
Oh, if it's spring water, that's even better.
If we connect some pipes, we can draw up a large amount of
water.
Did you see anything inside we could latch onto?
Wait, what do you mean pipes?
There were signs of ancient ruins, so there should be
something to hook onto.
Why?
Well, I was checking the wreckage of my spacecraft.
I found some wires and hooks, so...
Wow!
We!
Your stream went crazy!
What happened?
Cave diving is dangerous.
We're going to be...
reduced to a shape!
I made this hook gun!
Take it!
If there's something to latch onto, you can use this to move
quickly.
I was wondering about those!
There's like all those...
All those circles in there.
This should help you push through the current too.
I see.
That does sound useful.
Then, could you go into that cave where the clean water is
coming from and connect this pipe?
Once it's connected, bring the pipe out and attach it to the
purification device.
I'll lower down.
What?
The hook gone.
Aim and press.
Nice!
Ew, the electric eel has a funky smile.
Oh, we're about to...
No!
If I go into the lake again, I'll be worn out tonight.
Better save it for tomorrow.
I just gotta say, it's time for the restaurant.
Aw, man.
I'm gonna go fishing some more.
No!
Alright.
We have...
things that are high level
like so much tilapia but this is more yummy and cost more
how much is it to enhance holy cow but if we keep getting
electric eel then it might be good
one second there we go don't read facts about tilapia why
but it's so yummy maybe i shouldn't we're enhancing
did we get the elephant before already
oh become one with the elephant
oh yeah okay so we'll put that on the menu oh wait there we
go I'll just auto supply, yeah.
Um, we'll do...
Oh, these are not very yummy at all, are they, huh?
We can enhance this, too.
And we'll add it to the menu.
And we're getting our really yummy stuff in now.
Because some of these things that we've been serving are
like...
Oh, five.
Oh, you know, whatever.
Nah, we want the...
We want the deliciousness.
I have been addressed.
Address me.
Oh, the grass carp.
Nah, we'll do this.
Okay.
Wait.
Is there anything we can research?
Nope.
Okay.
Waitress, my food has a live fish in it.
Yeah?
And the problem is...
Muna!
What do you want?
What can I help you with?
Oh, uh...
Yeah!
She's sipping happily.
Yes.
I got it.
I got you.
Muna.
There you go.
Yes.
Oh, we found out Muna's preference.
Storming to death here.
All right.
Oh, yes.
Anything for you, my queen?
Oh, everybody's getting this.
Everyone's getting the eel.
Oh my gosh, please.
She's getting another one.
let's go holy cow we're about out we are out it's mighty
tasty oh shoot
okay nice tip nice tip what can i get for you sir okay okay
we got this we got this nobody got the salad
my eels are selling like eel cakes i do love Give me some
eel though.
Yahoo!
Oh!
Wait, that's the same as yesterday.
That's the same as before.
Just kidding.
They heard you were talking about salads earlier.
Oh, the parasite has hit!
The parasite has hit the village too!
Phew, long day.
Maybe I'll look around a bit before bed?
Sure.
have to talk to Muna.
She's gonna make us a thing.
Muna, my dear, where are you?
Muna?
Does she sleep already?
Maybe she's in...
Oh, there she is.
I just went into her tent.
Whoa!
That really does look like the breathing apparatus from that
stone tablet.
Hmm.
With this, I can finally start some real research.
if I compare it with the records of the village chief gave
me now that I think about it I spotted something glowing
down below everything else was stained yellow by the
hydrogen sulfide but this one piece stayed completely clean
may I take a closer look what could this be a sunang stone
have you heard of the sunang civilization
civilization she is like a hungay from a attack on titans.
Maybe it's a reference.
It's said to have existed in the region in ancient times.
I think I read about it in a book once.
An ancient civilization wiped out by a sudden rise in sea
level.
She lava lava.
Wait.
La lava.
Civilization.
But I thought it was just a legend.
It's real.
Sure later, generations may have exaggerated parts of it,
but the civilization itself did exist about 12,000 years ago
the Sunan civilization thrives on abundant mineral resources
she has a creepy otaku laugh like you just because I'm an
otaku and I'm always laughing doesn't mean that it's creepy
but it was submerged by a sudden ice age and massive
flooding but the Sunan people scattered across the world and
are believed to have laid the foundations of modern human
civilization Are you sure?
Are you an Otako too?
And?
There's even a theory that those who are submerged evolved
into the sea people!
A truly revolutionary idea!
Anyway, the Sunang Stone was essential for creating various
artifacts back then.
It contains highly concentrated energy.
How you use it makes all the difference.
If we harness its energy, we can make the jungle gun even
stronger.
You'll notice a whole new level of performance compared to
the materials we've been using.
Well, then I'll take a closer look at the breathing
apparatus.
It feels like everything's finally starting to come
together, thanks to the materials you've been finding.
Mint was always my favorite color and favorite tea flavor.
I love mint tea, too.
And it's a great color.
Hey yo how goes Aminto hello hello hello hello let's see
maybe we can then upgrade our jungle guy oh we need the tin
ingot how do I find that and we can either go for power or
machine machine gun but I need the Goliath Tigerfish oh okay
okay well I probably want the power rifle we'll go for this
so Goliath Tigerfish tooth I need a Goliath Tigerfish and
iron ingots nah No.
Harpoon gun.
Wait, what's the difference?
Assure?
I'm sort of an otaku myself.
Oh, we maxed it!
And we can probably get more...
Nice.
Even the cutest laugh is creepy when it comes to your walls
while you're sleeping at night.
Doesn't make it less cute though!
I mean sorry, it can't help it if I'm laughing through the
walls that like...
It might just sound a little strange, you know.
Let's go find some lizards.
Lizard, lizard, lizard, lizard, lizard, lizard.
Uh...
Yes, go to the cave.
Okay.
I guess talking to Bancho is something else too.
but there has to be is this the blue eye the big lizard I
think so oops
hmm am I already out of bait no let's see if we can find a
really good lizard I mean they're all good but
hmm are you sleepy?
do you want to come to my restaurant?
I'm going to gift you a a Moss ball.
Oh, wow.
Moss ball.
Thank you for thinking of me, Dave.
Oh!
We'll now be a customer!
Oh my gosh.
Every girl, get a girl a moss ball and she'll come to your
restaurant.
Mint is in the molecules around you.
Now, what does that mean?
Oh, wait, can I...
Oh, dang it.
I wanted to...
I wanted to ride it.
Wait, that kind of looks like...
Agumon, though.
A little bit, maybe.
Alright, we're gonna go find a really good lizard.
Oh, my stupid flower.
My flower is sad.
Uh, what do you want me to do about that?
What the heck is that?
Uh.
Okay.
sure it's tracking me lizard zeller I'm going to battle and
require your strongest lizard sorry come to think of it why
doesn't he have any tattoos should I ask sure I'm nosy I've
been wondering why don't you have any tattoos huh only
adults get tattoos oh this is the jaka this is the on that
lady's son you have to go through the coming of age ceremony
to get one oh I see everyone else in the village has them
but you don't you keep making me on I'm sorry it's a village
tradition so I guess I'll have to but I heard it really
hurts hi hello Alex thank you for the majority of the 27
months Kevin please watch your bank account
Do I really have to?
My coming of age ceremony is coming up soon, too.
You're becoming an adult soon.
Congrats in advance.
What's so great about becoming an adult?
Just more chores around the village.
All I want to do is lose myself in music with my panting?
What?
Music is the only real joy this village allows.
I get that, but people say being an adult can be a...
It'll be pretty fun in its own way.
Do you guys agree with that?
Do you guys agree?
You can drink beer and...
You can play that game where you steal cars and drive around
the city.
Not if it never comes out.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I want to be alone now.
Yikes.
Yikes forever.
Beer in GTA.
Guys, keep your eyes peeled for lizard.
Ah.
Oh.
I guess we'll go to bed.
Wait, I think I just saw a lizard.
I think I just saw an orange lizard.
Being an adult is fun because I can send me...
Mito money.
Nihon, who is it this early in the morning?
Sounds like a Muna.
I should go check.
Path to the forest.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you.
What brings you here so early?
Sorry about that.
There's something important.
Could you come to my tent?
Yeah.
All right, Yohan.
Oh, don't say y'all.
It's pretty fun.
I don't think so.
Wow, this is fun.
You're so right.
No?
We beg to differ.
Who says?
It's kind of fun.
You guys need to get better hobbies and go out more.
I agree.
I love sending bit money she deserves.
No!
Especially not if your bank is saying it's size.
Sending... Sending money is not fun, but sending free
supazes.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
This is actually pretty fun.
What?
What's wrong with you guys?
Dave, I think I figured it out after putting together the
materials you've brought me look right here see someone
wearing something on their head and going down into the sea
oh my god i too am very responsible adult you're right
giving fun giving bito buddies touch grass i mean not grass
but i can confirm this is super fun it's not more fun than
gta right it's it's fun completely agree i spend money to go
outside to see minto across country okay i i i can't i can't
give you any flack about that i do i do that but in
different country oh my gosh there's too many for me to read
man i love free supas i mean they're not quite but fun
rhymes with funds so it's true not quite fun message is fun
to send we're having so much fun this was free and not says
da yo it's free if you do it with friends certified super
fun time This is more fun than GTA.
I've had lots of fun today.
Definitely more fun than GTA.
Yeah, free Supers are fun.
Don't tempt me now.
I concur.
Does someone say free Supa?
I too will join in.
No!
Thank God.
Supas are free today.
Money's been a bit tight.
No!
Don't say that.
I feel so bad.
It's so much more fun, especially when free.
Why are they free?
They're not free.
And it's not fun.
It's not fun, it's not fun, it's not fun, it's not fun,
Supas are so fun, thank you guys for the Super Chats.
The red ones are even more fun, I think.
Oh, Fizzin'um.
Oh my god.
Free Supa Wednesday.
It's not, it's not, oh my gosh.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Ah!
Thank you!
Wee!
Better investment than GTA.
This is fun and totally free.
Weeks of fun!
Weeks of fun, weeks of fun.
Oh my gosh, Lance, thank you for that!
It was Super Chatter paid for my kidney meds.
I picked correctly.
Oh, fuck.
Double the supers for double the fun.
No!
Do we get a physical disc with these supers?
I provide you nothing but my anguish.
It can't be fun.
Did someone say fun?
It's not fun.
It's...
I already actually...
Well, okay.
I was going to say, I don't know what you guys get out of
it, but then when I send a super chat to...
to vtuber or to streamer i'm like
one more for murphy stop bullying your oshi with money is
the best that sounds like a like extortion sending money to
minto is fun
i buy too much merch to be able to super chat that's okay
too you should you should buy merch instead you should buy
merch because that's much you get something you get
something physical out of it you know that's enjoyable who
got it on this would be so fun fun fun fun fun fun hello Zen
Zulu thank you I hear that Apocera is free I'm they're only
free if it's not to me you guys you have it all wrong oh my
F is for friends, you do stuff together U is for you and me
And it's for anywhere And anytime and all down here in the
Minto stream
They're definitely free To Victoria Roman Sorry for bullying
you Here's a fun super by way of apology What the heck This
is pretty fun I just got done making dinner, show up to
stream And we're throwing money at Minto No Funds are fun.
They're even more fun when they're in your bank account.
Did you know?
In all seriousness, I'm bored at work while listening to the
stream, keeping me through the night.
Good luck with work, Lance!
Minto merch link doko.
Well, I have no merch out right now.
I don't think.
Merch on Monday?
maybe a little
I know this joke is running its course but you honestly
deserve it glad you are in better spirits no pun intended
thank you I'm going to have fun too I think she hates me
hopefully she hates me she hates me this is a made lilac and
therefore it's free oh sure so if it's her frog bird don't
give that guy money he'll he'll he don't know what you don't
want to know what he's going to use it for me to catch ah 1
Mintillion Supers Thank you guys for all the Super Chats
Thank you very very much Born too late to explore the sea
Born too soon to explore the stars Born just in time to
Super Chats Mint Phantom Channel At this time, at this very
moment You are able to do that That's so true Does Frogbear
even understand the concept of money?
I don't think that guy understands the concept of Being It's
hard to cast it again but when you you
when you yawn it's super calming stop say yawn we could do
mint colored supers I do like that color thank you on behalf
of the folks who can't join in on the fun right now this
one's for you and Minto too of course please give this to my
wife lilac what do you think her name is a lilac Phantom?
Mr. Phantom?
You think that her name, because I'm Mint Phantom, that she
would be Lilac Phantom?
Free soup or chat?
As much as I like chat.
Soup.
Yum soup.
At the time, at this particular place, all within the
confines of a Minto stream?
May I see it?
Yes.
How is it?
unfair uppercut to my melatonin.
Hi.
Hi Star Creator!
Okay.
I'm gonna go get some water and then we'll keep playing
game.
Thank you guys.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Be right back.
Thank you!
So fast.
I thought I was just getting water.
Just getting...
Thank you for the Who is a...
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right, let's get back to day of the dive or...
You're right.
The ancient Sanang people used the breathing apparatus you
found to survive even in hydrogen sulfide.
And here in the book the chief gave me, it looks like
they're wearing some kind of cloth wrapped around their
bodies.
Exactly!
Not just the breathing apparatus, they also wore special
cloths to protect themselves!
Let me catch my breath.
Do you know what the really shocking part is?
It's that the Sinang breathing apparatus and protective gear
are stored in a nearby temple.
Heart.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
And I guess we should head to that temple.
From what I found, it's within walking distance.
But the path through the forest was blocked by a recent
earthquake.
Maybe the village chief knows another way?
possible let's go ask together yeah yeah oh my gosh it
belongs in a museum what a my bank becomes size no they're
on to you they're on to you the feds they're on to you
oh wait a moment Dave about that Sunang stone you showed me
yesterday have you seen any other glowing materials or
minerals in the lake i think i might have but the water was
so murky i can't be sure.
Those minerals contain sparkling more crystals inside.
I've developed a machine.
That melts the protective layer!
Oh, yes!
The laser emitter model S.
If you keep shining this on those minerals, the protective
layer melts away.
And ta-da!
You can extract the Sunang stone inside.
I thought they were eggs.
Leaving soon.
Thanks for hanging out!
With that stone, I could make the jungle gun even stronger.
I'll give you this laser emitter for free for now.
Though upgrading to a higher model will cost you.
Thanks, I'll try it out in the lake right away.
But first we should head to the village chief's house and
ask for directions to the temple.
You're right, let's go see the chief first.
Peepie!
Oh good!
I thought they were eggs.
Wait, now I'm kind of disappointed that they're not eggs.
You know?
Before we talk to the village chief, I want to go to the
freshwater area.
Wait, I'm watching some fish.
Wait, do you see these guys?
Wait, my head's in the way.
You see, wait, you see them right there?
They're like buried in there.
Do you think I could get them from here?
I keep clicking left click, but it's not working.
No!
Yeah.
That's a lot!
That's a whole lot!
You contributed to.
Professional idiot.
That's so mean to claw.
I feel like that's so mean for me to say, though.
Even though it's just your username.
Alright, we're going down, down.
Down, down.
We're going down, down.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, is this amber?
Oh, it is.
Wait, so how do I...
Oh, wait.
Whoa!
Think we could take him on again?
Call me an idiot.
No!
Wait a second.
Did my thing get stronger?
Oh, shoot.
Wrong guy.
Oh!
Good thing we dodged.
If I change my...
If I change my username, does that mean I can get Minto to
insult me?
Don't...
I mean, you already did.
You already did, kind of.
That's the...
That's the sturgeon.
The sturgeon.
Nice.
What are you guys?
They're strong, whatever they are.
But they're so tiny.
Catfish.
Wow.
The sturgeon surgeon.
Yay, go!
Large mouth by yes.
Where the heck is the fresh water?
Oh, there it is.
Martin asked me to connect a pipe where the clean water
flows out.
Okay.
I should try using the hook gun in that latch.
Yes.
Whoa.
Moving that fast made my ears pop.
Let's install the pipe in the water source, like Martin
said.
Yeah, but what's this?
Murphy!
Welcome back?
More!
Thank you, Kevin!
My hungry...
Bass could never be a sturgeon.
Never say never.
What's this?
Oh, this oxygen.
Duh.
Alright, it's Akira.
Now let's grab the pipe and ride the current back out.
Wee!
Very slowly, apparently.
Apparently, very- Oh!
Now, what does that do?
That made me dizzy.
Why aren't I connected the pipe and brought it back?
That's the perfect spot!
Alright, then I'll send the purification device down to you.
The fish that run away from it.
So this is the purification device.
It's pretty big.
Took quite a bit of work to build.
Now go ahead and connect the pipe you brought to it.
Okay.
But
won't this ruin the ecosystem of the fish that already can
survive in this climate?
Like, doesn't this also disrupt the ecosystem?
The device is working.
Just as expected, Kindred technology works perfectly
anywhere.
The lake should be much clearer by tomorrow.
Glad it turned into a nice parting gift.
I'll try contacting the rescue ship again.
Okay.
It'll be better this way, maybe.
Maybe they don't actually like it.
Is this a guy a grouper?
Part of me thinks he just has grouper vibes.
But he's actually a loner.
He's all by himself.
No?
Hey!
Oh, we got him.
Oh, Nile Purr!
I like that brand.
Wait, can I go down?
Oh, better not go down now.
Okay, okay.
Is that sturgeon still over here?
Oh, he is.
Oh, look at a snail.
He's looking at me.
I'm looking at him.
You missed the pun.
Actually, no, it's...
There's no pun.
It's just that there's a clothing brand I like.
Called Nile Perch.
But now I'm confused why it's called that.
This, what is this?
Giant catfish.
Wait, is that the one that will give me the tooth that I
need for the upgrade?
Maybe we should take him out.
You think I can take him?
Oh!
Oh shoot.
The ammo's down here.
He's poisoned me.
Ah!
Nice.
Hot dog, yeah?
Oh, not hot dog.
Not hot dog moment.
Uh oh.
I'm out of...
Okay.
Alright.
Oop!
Maybe?
Oh!
Oh my god, so bad.
Get more oxygen fast.
Please.
Thank you.
Holy cow.
Please, please.
Death, death, death.
Ouch!
Oh, please, please, please!
No, you're too close.
I think we're close!
Probably!
We took this guy out!
Yeah!
He didn't give me what I needed.
Oh, epic battle.
Epic battle for real.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Eh?
Oh!
We're about to run out of, uh...
We'll leave because our thing is gonna run out anyway soon.
Our filter.
I guess we'll see if the lake is clear tomorrow.
Yeah!
Little laser.
And we got so much stuff.
Nice.
What is that?
this oh we're reading one up oh yeah I think it's about time
to ask the village chief for a rating upgrade I should
invite him over for an evaluation oh I'm getting hungry
tonight I'm gonna have breakfast for dinner I'm having bacon
I'm having eggs I'm having toast staying away from lettuce
what the heck are you What art?
What is that?
What is this?
Oh, he's flossing.
Oh.
Oh, the monkey is breakdancing.
What's happening?
Vivica?
What the fuck is it?
What's happening?
We've reached a monkey!
A new slot plus one.
Placeable grills.
Oh, new recipes.
Stir-fried spicy king oyster mushrooms.
Walking catfish Tomium.
Grilled mud carp with herbs.
Sweet and sour grommy.
Delicious.
Morai Temple, you say.
To reach it, you'll need to pass through the Seta Forest.
However, as you know, a massive boulder fell during the
recent earthquake and is blocking the path.
Join the mini-concert with Densetsu, hoping you'll get to
come down to Australia next time.
Thank you!
I hope so, too.
There's no way to the temple now just go around the boulder
it's not impossible you just need to move that boulder that
huge boulder it won't be easy with just a few of you the
villagers must be unhappy with the rock blocking the path
like that couldn't we just push it together that's the
problem the villagers aren't bothered by the path being
blocked in fact they prefer it it keeps wild animals from
coming up here they wouldn't be pleased if i asked them to
move it just to help outsiders
visible walls exist.
It's not a boulder.
It's a rock.
A rock.
What shall we do?
You probably need three more adults.
Why not get to know the villagers and ask for their help?
If they trust you, they'll help, even with difficult
requests.
You'll be staying here for a while anyway.
Wouldn't it be hurt to build some relationships?
Get closer to the villagers.
Building trust at the Sea People Village was pretty
exhausting.
Guess we better get stuck.
part of.
I hate being social.
Affinity level 3 or higher?
Oh, man.
Uh, what are we at?
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to touch.
What's your favorite things?
Coral.
Oh, whoops, sorry.
Um, coral.
Coral for oozing.
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
Rimbo, we're close, we're close to three.
Lati, Lipa, and Uzma, we're close.
So let's give Uzma some coral and maybe.
Come on.
Do I have any coral?
I must.
So far no lizards.
Yeah.
But...
That was creepy.
Blue coral.
Blue coral?
The village is quite far from the sea, but sometimes blue
coral washes up like this.
Isn't the color beautiful?
Oh, it'll display nicely in my room.
Thank you so much.
Yes!
All right.
The village has felt more lively.
Boncho's food is so delicious, too.
I don't know how he makes it taste so good with the same
ingredients.
Actually, Boncho specializes in sushi, not grilling.
make it here.
I see.
I'd love to try it someday.
I thought it might be nice to decorate Bancho's shop a
little bit more, so I prepared this.
Do you think he'll like it?
It's really pretty.
Did you make it yourself?
Wait, she's decorating our place?
I wove it using things I found on the beach, or that Rimbos
sometimes brings me.
Wouldn't he like it more if he gave it to him yourself?
Eek!
That would be far too embarrassing.
I'll make sure he gets decoration cute all right so we need
to talk about the boulder trying to clear the boulder could
you give me a hand oh you mean moving the boulder it's good
that wild animals stay away but we can't keep the path
blocked forever i'll help you let me know when you're ready
all right that's one person let's go ask my girlfriend
there's so many people i haven't talked to oh my girlfriend
hello
about the boulder trying to clear the boulder could you give
me a hand you mean that big boulder on the forest path right
well the animals have been having trouble getting past it
too alright you might as well clear it just let me know when
everyone's ready alright nice and then there was one more
person
wait Rimbo Rimbo what's your favorite thing I'm pretty
attached to this year truck there's no truck here It's a
pony pickup truck.
Made in Korea.
It's been a real help haul and stuff through the rough
jungle roads.
Red is his favorite color.
Okay, so let's gift something.
Maybe an amber?
Or...
Not bad.
Oh, you kind of liked it.
Not enough to...
We can't gift another thing!
Well, there was one.
one other person.
Pony in Korea.
Maybe this guy over here.
Yeah, yeah.
Dave, how's the investigation going?
It's going well, but the creatures have gotten a lot more
aggressive.
I'm having a bit of trouble gathering ingredients.
I see.
I can't help with other ingredients, but I can share some
herbs and spices.
I'll give you free herbs and spices every day.
Wow!
Just come when you need them.
I'll add a few more ingredients to the shop.
I'm counting on you.
Thai chili sambal sauce palm sugar.
Oh, we got the palm sugar.
One free lemongrass?
The price is free!
Boulder.
JFC jungle fried chicken.
Trying to clear the boulder, could you give me a hand?
Alright, please gather more people.
See you at the rock when everything's ready.
Alright, let's head back to the village chief's house.
Very nice.
Wait, what is this guy?
What's happening?
Is that a stag beetle?
First time I've seen one around here, when it comes to
collecting, you can't beat stag beetles and rhinoceros
beetles.
Let's see if I can... Wait, there was a red lizard!
Oh no, I missed it!
That's okay.
I don't have a...
I don't have the, uh, what's it called?
The lizard bait anyway.
I need to order more.
The net tore!
The Stag Beetle's jaws are strong.
This net will hold up.
I should go find Muna to have her fix it.
Wait, does that mean I can't catch lizards either?
Because I was using the same net.
Wait, can I not catch anything anymore?
This is so lame.
the villagers
decided to help you I found luckily I found three people
willing to help let's head through the boulder together
looks like everyone's already here but this many people you
should be able to move it you won't need me just watch chief
will handle it ourselves let's get started aw yeah aw yeah
wheeve hole peeve Oh, hee!
Ha!
That was heavy.
When everyone works together, even something that big can be
moved.
Now we can finally use this path to reach the forest.
That's true, but with the recent earthquakes and unstable
conditions, the wild animals have become more aggressive.
If you head out there unprepared, you'll be easy prey.
You're right, going alone won't be easy.
Wait!
I know my way around land better than you do.
How about I tag along?
with you.
You'll need a weapon.
Wait, why are the animals aggressive because of the
earthquake?
Take this club.
I'll bring a gun.
Oh, okay.
I feel really safe with my club and you have the gun.
I'd like to use a gun, too.
You know, firearms on land require a separate license.
Don't worry, I'll keep you safe.
I'm the passenger, princess.
But, I haven't used a gun in a while.
It feels like I'm a bit rusty.
It'll be nice if somewhere nearby gets some shooting
practice.
Could you check around for me?
Shooting practice.
Rainbow knows this area pretty well.
I'll ask him.
Why don't we just go?
Where are we going?
We're going to the forest?
Come on, Cobra.
You could do shooting practice in the forest.
Look at everybody who's walking back.
Maybe...
Oh!
Yellow lizard.
Wait, I gotta go get you some lizard bait.
Wait, she's right here.
My girlfriend, please, I need to buy lizard bait right now.
Oh, wait.
Okay, she sold out.
Thank you, Lipa.
Maybe like here.
I think that's good.
No, my net!
I forgot.
No, stinking way.
Wait.
Wait, just hold on!
Little Lizard!
Where did she go?
Muna!
There she is.
Please, I need help.
Fix my net right now.
It's important!
I was trying to catch a stag, Betel.
Fixing is no problem.
Okay, I don't have a second.
I need like...
I need it right now.
Oh, thank goodness.
Good as new!
Okay.
How am I supposed to catch stag beetles?
With your hands.
Stag beetles around here are incredibly tough.
Same goes for the rhinoceros beetles.
I figured.
Maybe I should give up on those insects.
Alright.
Anyway, Muna, thank you so much.
I gotta go.
No, no, no, please.
Please!
My lizard, he's probably...
No!
He's done doing...
He's done doing that!
Oh, Dave!
Udo, what are you doing here?
What a coincidence running into you here.
Actually, our publishing house is launching a new magazine
project.
It's called Weekly Insects.
He's still there.
Okay.
We're covering insects from jungle regions like this.
If I can make this project a success, I'll finally become
editor-in-chief!
Dave, I see you're carrying in that.
Have you caught any insects around here?
There are quite a few interesting ones.
Since you're catching insects anyway, how about helping me
with my coverage?
The editorial team set me up with this...
Insectogram!
Ew!
Okay, I don't have time.
I don't have time.
Okay, blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Oh, you have to...
Make them fight?
You're gonna give me a baby Stag Beetle!
Then you're gonna make me fight them?
No, wait, that's so sad!
I have a lesser stag beetle.
Let's go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, wait, what's, why is my phone
vibrating?
he's not even on the tree anymore i wasted my money that was
so sad why is my phone vibrating isn't this one what do you
want what do you want seed what do you want seed
oh it's a new bug nearby okay i don't care so much focused
on the lizard.
Shooting practice.
Truth be told, I used to do a bit of shooting myself.
These days I've just been driving, so I've forgotten most of
it.
There's a spot deeper out by the beach where I used to
practice.
Come on, I'll show you the way.
Will you show me the way?
Well, well.
Was that a red lizard north?
Well, we're far away now.
I have to set it up out here because of the noise.
This is why we need this ladder.
Haven't been coming out here much lately So I took the
ladder down But I'll leave it here from now on Alright then
follow me What a thrill With darkness and sap New area Sand
dunes And they're the night
Wait I can make these guys No there was a beetle There's so
many Colorful flowers here Oh The soil is a bit different
from the village, so the plants and critters are different
too.
Different lizards?
Wait, what is in there?
If you go further in, you'll see even more unusual flora and
fauna.
The undergrowth's gotten real thick.
You'll need something like a machete to get through.
Let's head up the path to the shooting range.
Yes, get out of my way.
I have things that...
AHHHHH!
Let's start with something easy.
Wait, am I shooting?
No, we're just watching him shoot.
Oh, I am shooting.
Selected difficulty.
Oh, won't let me go past level 1, you guys.
Try reloading.
FPS.
FPS Gamer?
Oh, oops.
I guess I should have reloaded.
Nice.
Reloading.
Reminds me of Duck Hunt.
Oh, finish!
Yahoo!
Looks like you've got some skill.
Let's try the next level.
Doom POV.
Amazing.
Nice.
Oh.
Try shooting a moving target.
be tougher than a still target.
Try focusing.
It'll make it easier.
Oh.
I don't need to focus.
Oh, oops.
Oh, yes, I do.
Yes, I do.
Maybe I do.
Then frogs be fast.
Oh, shoot.
No, I lost the bear!
Oops.
I got him.
Oh, I missed a monkey.
Nah.
Oh, it's still S.
That was a walk in the park for you.
How about we make it a bit harder?
Wait, I'm still going?
Okay.
Oh, that's a person.
You don't see these human-shaped targets.
Best not hit the...
I straight up left-clicked immediately.
Hit the animal targets and avoid the human ones.
Okay.
They're really getting me with these, I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, reloading.
Oh, did I get that problem?
I don't know, actually.
I don't know if I did or not.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no, I missed it.
That's okay.
Oh.
It's so tempting.
It is.
Oh shoot, yeah, that's what you're supposed to do.
Excellent, well done.
Yeah, Metal Gear has trained me to aim at human targets.
Call it a day.
I think I'm a professional.
Now I'm getting the hang of it.
That's a relief.
I'll leave the shooting range open.
So feel free to use it anytime.
Can I come here and practice too?
Of course.
Besides what Cobra tried earlier, there are two more
difficult stages.
Whenever you want to use it, just climb up the ladder here.
Blue Heave-Hoe Doll.
I was wondering what these were.
They're dolls.
I'm getting warmed up.
I'll clean the firearms today and we'll head out at dawn
tomorrow.
Let's meet at the entrance to set a forest.
Okay, I should go get ready too.
What am I getting ready for?
I don't know.
I just want to go find a beetle.
There he is.
He's still here, you guys.
He's still here.
Yeah.
Baby Stag Beetle.
Fight!
Oh.
Wait, they're fighting for real?
Is this like a Pokemon?
You know what I mean?
That was my birthday!
I don't like it!
Scissors uses a horn attack.
Rock charges and paper heals.
Horn attack.
Wait, that's mine.
Uh-oh.
Which is this?
Oh, charge.
Charge.
Nah!
Oh, I'm so bad at this.
We're healing.
Charging.
We also picked charge.
Miss.
Uh.
Oh, I did not...
I clicked...
It's kind of confusing.
I'm not gonna lie.
We're getting cooked, for real.
Wait, what the hell?!
Wait, it's...
I mean, that's good, but also...
I'm so confused!
Don't kill me.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Is my stag beetle dead now?
Oh, my insect is stunned.
Oops.
Oh well.
Oh my god, it's a leopard gecko.
Shut up.
Oh my god, stop!
I don't care about the butterfly!
Dalmatian big eye!
Cute!
Swallow.
Now we're catching bugs.
This is really becoming just any type of game.
This is becoming every type of game, isn't it now?
I want to try the harder levels.
My photography business cards are here.
I got a business license.
I'm doing photography for legends!
That's Skyline's Aaron in.
Nervous but ready.
Seaboard!
Thank you for doing the...
Doing the...
Photography!
You got this.
It is a free-for-all.
What does that mean?
Oh, weak?
Wait.
Oh, oops.
It's just...
Dave is the one who shoots...
people on accident.
Oh, shoot.
Nice.
So I started blasting.
Oh, dang it.
Alright.
Weak is weak spot.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I almost shot a person.
Oh, I think I got the last guy.
There's even frogs!
Oh, what the?
There's bats?
Bats.
I got an A because I shot a human.
No!
Let me try again.
Glad you liked my lizard.
Yes, thank you!
Oh, I almost did it.
I almost did it again!
Yeah?
I almost had...
I almost had the weak spot there.
Gamer?
Oh, oh, the bats are up here!
Oh, I didn't even see them before!
Oh,
I didn't see them until they were moving.
Oh!
It's crazy.
Oops.
Wee!
Not even close.
Yeah!
Let's try level 5.
Alright, this is the hardest one, you guys.
Oh, dang it!
I messed up.
Oh.
Oh, I feel like my thing's getting out of sync.
It's weird.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Oh, tiger!
Oh, strong.
Nice.
Tiger, tiger.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Close.
Yippee!
Ah!
First try!
Oh yeah!
Sharp shooter, Minto.
Take some starfruit.
Oh, he cleaned up his whole spaceship.
It's all gone.
Oh.
How are you, Mendoza?
I hope you're doing wonderfully.
Thank you!
I'm doing good.
I hope you are too.
I have a talent for this.
Oh, this is the Beetle.
Nasty thing.
My guy is knocked out, so we can't.
Oh, man.
It's time for the restaurant already.
Okay.
I feel like the restaurant is my least favorite aspect.
Oh no, wait!
I'm so...
I'm so stupid.
Wait, I didn't add anything to the menu.
I didn't put anything on the menu.
Whoopsie, oopsie, oopsie.
Oopsie, oopsie, oopsie.
Oopsie, oopsie.
Oh.
People aren't coming, right?
Uh, we could do this guy.
Oh, no.
Actually, oh, wait.
Actually, wait.
Yeah, we'll swap it with this.
Wait, no, don't discard it.
Never mind.
Don't discard it.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
We can even research more stuff!
Researching on the job.
Good thing it, good thing it, pause the menu.
These sound effects go...
Cute!
Hungry.
We can try the research stuff next time.
That one was so cute though.
All the way over here.
Nice.
In it.
Ayang.
Perfect.
Perfect drink.
That stirred something inside me.
Yes, there you go.
Yes, yes.
So close?
Is that what Aeon is on?
Yeah, the Aeon is like nice.
It's...
It's just like nice.
Go, Bancho!
Go!
Nice!
I've just been saying it.
Well, to be fair, most people have been calling it Mecha
Chameleon.
I called it Mecha Chameleon at first, too.
I didn't realize it was a Japanese game.
I didn't realize.
Okay.
The app, the insect app is kind of annoying.
It's always beeping.
It's always going off.
I don't care about moths.
I don't want a moth.
I don't want that.
Bug shop?
I could buy more stag beetles.
Wait, I'm rich.
Do you see how much money I have?
Crazy.
I could get a really good rhinoceros.
Rhinoceros beetle.
And I can get this for my fainted guys.
Okay.
I don't remember what Udo did before.
Oh, Firefly.
Firefly?
Cute!
Wait, this is also...
This guy also looks really powerful, though.
Wait, what are we doing over here?
What is the heart plus?
Muna?
Are you in love with me?
Muna looks...
looking at something.
Maybe I just talked to her.
Did you find anything unusual?
Oh, Dave, it's nothing major.
He asked you to take pictures and capture special fish.
Ah, that's right, that's right.
Yeah, before.
So it's Mecha Chameleon.
Yeah, it's a Mecha Chameleon.
Firefly from Honkai Star Rail.
That's gonna activate the neurons of several people.
Oh, this is...
I was just examining the soil around here.
Just like in my research, it's quite acidic.
It's hard to grow crops in acidic soil.
Which means the farmer in the village must be putting in a
lot of care.
I saw it translated as super chameleon from a Japanese
tweet.
It threw me off hard.
Well, I mean, that's basically what it means.
It's like, yeah, like super chameleon.
Like, I am met a chameleon right now.
chameleon right now guys i am like so chameleon right now
treat shut up so she means that grumpy guy i guess he treats
his crops well by the way i heard things got pretty intense
with dr bacon in the blue hole yeah honestly i only went
because they said i could eat all the sushi i wanted but it
was still fun i made lots of good friends yeah i'm chameleon
maxing.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna metcha chameleon right now.
Can you see me?
I'm so chameleon right now.
You guys don't even know how chameleon I am right now.
I'm like so chameleon.
Minky, mecha kawaii.
Mecha chameleon.
Okay, okay.
I'll give up my spot.
Next time take me with you, I'll stay up a lot.
It'd be fun to go together.
Though hopefully not as dangerous as last time.
Muno wants me.
Look at the way she's looking at me.
Found her!
No, I gave up.
Can we...
Wait, is this a beetle?
Oh, it is.
No!
Wait, we're the same.
1352...
No, no.
No, no, no, give up, give up.
Oh, he left.
I'm looking for lizards.
Lizard, lizard, lizard, lizard, lizard, lizard.
Wait, what are you?
What are you?
Oh, we might be able to take this guy on.
Our attack is higher.
I think I'm not good at this game, though.
There was one nearer.
her.
Oh, really?
Siamese rhinoceros, be it those.
Um, I'm gonna I'm gonna take the charge.
Whoa!
I'm gonna horn attack?
Oh, he's charging!
Ow!
I'm gonna charge at him?
Yeah, I'll take the charge.
Yeah!
I'm gonna horn attack.
Oh, no, he's charged.
I thought he was gonna defend.
I thought he would defend.
We're both charging.
Miss.
Oh, never mind.
He took a little bit more than me.
Yeah!
Aw, man.
That's okay.
Oh, he regained a lot.
Holy cow.
That's okay.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna horn attack.
Yes!
Yeah!
I thought he would...
Oh my gosh!
We almost got him!
I'm gonna horn attack again.
Yes!
We got his butt!
Oh!
What does that mean?
Oh, he's mine now.
Yoink.
Oh, there's more stuff happening here.
Oh, sir.
Perfect timing.
Our friend Yasuto has finally recovered from his illness.
Oh my god, he's alive!
The one who got bitten by a spider and couldn't join the
investigation.
That's a relief.
I had a nightmare all night about being chased by thousands
of spiders.
Minto's truly a beetlemon master.
Yeah, baby.
It's a real shame I couldn't take part in the investigation.
But thanks to you, sir, we managed to get a photo of the
UFO.
There's definitely some kind of mysterious power in this
village.
Wasn't the UFO?
That guy?
So about that, Fukuo, Takeru, I've decided to stay in this
village.
Wait, you're not coming with us on our grand journey?
It's not like that.
I just feel like there are more mysteries to uncover here.
I'd love for you guys to say too, but...
You have a duty to seek out other mysteries.
Our minke is the horniest.
Oh, that's...
Oh, maybe no.
You're right, it's a choice we must make for the greater
good.
It's an unavoidable fate.
Yasuto, your noble sacrifice will be remembered, even if we
part ways here.
The Shimano University Mystery Research Club will always be
together.
The music is so funny.
As I mentioned, I'm planning to stay here for a while.
Right, get some rest and keep up with your research.
But just staying, doing nothing but research feels a bit
awkward.
So would it be alright if I worked at your restaurant?
Oh, okay.
My father runs a ramen shop.
I know a bit about cooking and serving.
That sounds great.
We've actually been a bit short-handed.
I'm sure Bancho will be happy to hear that.
Thanks for having me.
Now that I think about it.
coming out of my hands.
Like, like that character!
Yeah, when I bend my wrist like this, white threads come
out.
Maybe we could use this to help with serving.
Hello?
It might work.
Then let's meet at the shop when you're ready.
Wait.
We're just gonna let Yasuto fling his web all over the food?
Oh my god he does!
Yasuto has joined... what is this game?
What has happened?
Yasuto has joined Bancho Grill as a staff member.
He can use special spider web techniques.
I see an orange guy.
Lizard.
Yoink!
Red line big eye.
I'm gonna go give them to her.
I have really cute lizards for you ma'am.
hopefully I can make it there before before they tell me to
go to sleep please there she is she's still outside gift can
I give her the list I can this one's brand new a red lion
big eye this is quite a rare species you were lucky to find
it really the cook Colors were so pretty, I couldn't resist.
I said, thank you.
Let me give you some lizard bait.
I hope we can keep getting along well.
Can I give you more?
I have an even cuter guy.
No!
That's fine.
I kind of want him for myself.
Dave is winning.
She wants me.
Rest for tomorrow.
I should get some rest.
I kind of want to dive.
I kind of keep playing.
This game is so fun.
Oh wait, we're going to this at the forest.
Let's head to where the big boulder was.
Okay, we can do this real quick.
Because I think I'm...
I'm afraid I will forget.
There's so many NPCs in this game.
Like, so many people to talk to.
It's so much.
And this is the DLC!
This isn't even the main game!
Yeah, let's go to the forest!
Have you eaten?
I haven't.
I just want to see the forest, then I'll call it quits.
How many lizards are in here?
Wait, there's just like creatures roaming about.
The trees are so dense here.
Now this is a proper jungle.
It's dangerous on your own, so don't fall behind!
Fall behind.
You're the one following me, man.
Any lizards around?
Wait.
Alright, guy.
That's a thing.
Take him out.
That's a big, wild rat.
The chief did say the creatures in the forest have gotten
more aggressive.
Are the rats aggressive?
They might attack if we get too close.
Yeah, that's why you have a gun.
Blue.
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
We're suddenly... We're Final Fantasy?
You guys, just...
Just hit.
Apply only basic attacks, okay?
Skill?
Sniper rifle?
On the giant rat?
Okay.
Oh, it requires AP.
Enemy turn.
Press.
Wait, I...
Oh.
Looks like you're warmed up?
Wait, this is so funny.
Okay.
He's bite?
Ouch.
Oh, I keep forgetting to press the...
When am I supposed to press it?
Ouch.
I thought it was dead, I'm not gonna lie.
Right before you hit.
Maybe when the...
Maybe when you...
Maybe when it's...
Oh, here we go.
The exclamation point happens.
Blizzard Bay.
Little baby!
Can I get it?
Can I get him?
Hello?
Skills?
Skill you snack!
No, no, no.
Wait, what?
Let me get him!
Manual?
Closer?
Oh, it's gone.
No!
So sad.
What are these?
No!
But it wouldn't- it didn't show up at all!
It's not manual, it should be auto.
That's so sad.
So sad, so sad.
I missed out on my little guy.
Little blue guy.
Wait, he's back!
He's back!
Don't ruin this for me, you stupid rat.
me you stupid rat okay maybe equipment accessories okay
items is it under no
no okay well at least got it back what
the heck What the hell is that?
Oh, these things are just sick!
Oh,
it's a wolf spider!
Nice!
Get the news!
Oh,
nice, nice, he's stupid.
It jumps, yeah, it's disgusting.
Can I...
Oh.
I can't time it at all.
What's our skit?
Oh!
Restores one!
Oh, there's HP.
Yeah!
We're still running?
Powerful, most powerful guy.
He's camping even.
Okay.
Dave with the belly attack.
Yeah.
He's camping, he's camping.
They don't want you to just run through the map.
Yee!
That's scary.
I think we're gonna die.
It does make the shooting gallery pointless, doesn't it?
Uh-oh.
Cobra is gotten by the cobra.
Um...
I wish we could...
Oh, no, just kidding.
I'm stupid.
Ouch.
We're gonna die.
guys this is it Dave is down Dave is down how would I repeat
that's
okay we'll return to the village and we'll try again next
time it's okay I didn't actually think that we would make it
through the forest so that's why I was okay with doing it.
But I think I will call it here for today, guys.
Of course, as always, David Iver is so addicting.
So, so addicting.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
One last thing before I leave.
I see the green lizard there.
We'll let him be free.
Because there was one thing I wanted to check.
was the condition of the water.
They said it was much clearer now.
It looks kind of clear, no?
Wait.
Okay, one more thing.
Okay, Columbo.
I just wanted to see the water.
Hope you feel a little better.
Make you happy breakfast in there.
I hope your ears are coming around.
Thank you.
go to the doctor somewhere recently.
They said I have no more infection.
Yahoo!
But I still have fluid, so I have to be careful.
I actually ordered a new pair of headphones.
That, um, they are the, uh, they're, they're the ones that,
like, clip over the back of your ear.
So, they don't go in my ear, but they don't go around my
head and push my ears down.
So, um, hopefully, uh, they, they, hopefully they work.
Not bone conduction.
Um, I did some research into some of them.
Hold on, I'll get a picture of them.
Because I think I'm not describing it very well.
Oh, no, I'm signed out on my account.
Uh, it's not bone conduction.
You can't say bone conduction.
When I just said it's not bone conduction.
Let's see.
What are they called?
I just did all...
I just looked...
Gosh, I'm silliness.
They don't arrive for a couple days anyway, so...
These ones are the ones I got.
And if I hate them, they were...
very inexpensive they were twenty dollars they were twenty
dollars so if they're if they really suck i don't lose so
much like this sorry for the random man jump scare yeah cost
they're the cost ksc 75 and they seem to be pretty decent um
people were saying that and
do you get a beard too?
I sure hope so.
I'll double check the listing and see.
I'll make sure.
They look like they're from the 2000s.
They look really nostalgic, no?
I thought it would be...
I was like, wow, I completely forgot about this style of
headphones.
I think it would be fun to have it for...
For my streams, maybe.
Yeah.
Beard not included?
Oh, man.
I'm getting ripped off for real.
But yeah, okay.
Let's get through Dave real quick and then...
Thank you very much for the stream, just letting you know
that I'm always rooting for you.
Thank you, Beard.
Thank you.
It reminds me of the headphones I used to give away on the
airplane flights for in-flight movies.
Do they really use to give away ones like these?
Let's see.
Lake really cleared up.
Looks like there's some new fish too.
Now the villagers have one less thing to worry about.
Alright.
So it really did clear up.
Right now it looks like regular Dave the Diver game.
It looks like how it used to play.
No more fart water.
Woohoo!
Yeah.
What?
Oh, I killed him.
I killed a fish.
But yeah.
I don't like in here just because I feel like I have to
clean them every time it's icky.
That's why I'm hoping these work out.
I'm really crossing my fingers.
Fingers crossed for them.
So, yammy!
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you, thank you!
I hope you guys had fun with the Dave the Diverness that we
did.
And, um, we talked, I feel like I talked way more than I
played the game, but that's okay.
Sorry again today, I'm just feeling a little bleh.
So, um, I currently use the Sennheiser HD 599 SE.
They're super comfortable.
Wait, I want to see.
I'm looking them up.
Oop.
Oh, I have to be really careful with over-ear headphones,
though.
They make me so...
They make me not so great, to be honest.
Thank you for the streaming, though.
It was so much fun.
It's crazy how much is in this DLC.
I know!
So many different minigames and subplots to dive into.
Hope your breakfast for dinner is delicious.
Thank you, Dorgo!
Thank you!
As an alternative, have you looked into...
Open back headphones.
Oh.
Oh, I, I have, oh my gosh, I'm trying to copy your, oh my
gosh, I'm just trying to copy, YouTube, please.
I have, like, kind of, I have thought about it, I just don't
know if they will be, um, still pushing on my heads too
much.
The cups are large, the audio quality is top notch.
if these are if the ones that the $20 ones are not good then
I will get I will look more into the open back ones because
I have been really interested in them yeah yapping with
minkees essential time well it's it's a it was a free chat
plus game free chat but Dave sometimes stream
open back and large ear cups turned out to be the solution
for many people with sensitive ears I really love my IEM so
I'm quite sad that it seems that they don't work for me and
they're also great because they're so portable but um oh
sorry Dave we're not gonna do that but yeah anyway thank you
guys thank you thank you they don't grip my head very hard
but stay on it's not my head it's my ears like the like my
earlobes and stuff start aching like My ears are so
sensitive.
I guess it's because they're pointy.
But like, the cartilage around my ears is very, very
sensitive.
So, I don't know.
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah.
I get the same issue.
Kind of pulsating pain.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Most people don't have pointy ears.
Well, most people...
Actually, there are a lot of ghosts.
I was going to say most people aren't ghosts, but there are
actually so many ghosts.
Anyway.
Thank you, guys.
I used my Sennheiser 598 set for a decade.
Wow.
598.
Oh, they're still over here, though.
Yeah.
Oh, I would have to try them in person, probably.
Oh, but they're also open back.
They don't get hot.
Thank you, Manef.
Thank you so much for the recommendation.
Matsumito, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Bye-bye.
Three to five dollar headphones from Daiso.
That is a steal.
Good night.
Bye-bye.
And thanks for being so patient with me.
I don't know.
I think today, especially, I feel...
I feel like so...
Like, how do I say?
Like, I don't know, I feel like I'm really disappointing
people lately.
And I just feel, ah, my brain is all bleh.
And, I don't know.
I just hope you guys like the outfit when I do get to debut
it.
I don't know.
I'm worried about disappointing people with that too.
And everything.
I'm sorry that I had to push the date.
But thank you for being patient with me.
Thank you.
Okay, bye!